[Musique]
alors quelle est la première chose qu'on
entend quelle est la première chose qui
me vient à l'esprit quand on entend le
mot argile alors peut-être que pour
certains ça va évoquer la poterie
peut-être que d'autres ça va évoquer la
céramique la cosmétique ou peut-être
tout simplement la boue mais est ce que
vous auriez pensé à la construction en
terre alors je vous rassure toutes les
maisons ne ressemble pas à celle ci donc
l'argile dans la construction en terre
joue le rôle de liant donc c'est ce qui
permet aux matériaux de se tenir et
d'être utilisé comme matériau de
construction
donc je suis chercheur ici halonen tpe
et je travaille sur la construction en
terre et avant ça ben moi j'avais fait
un master mais j'ai fait une thèse sur
la construction terre avant ça j'avais
fait un master sur la science des
argiles donc aujourd'hui je vous parle
est un petit peu de la construction en
terre est finalement un peu de la
résilience de nos façons de construire
mais surtout aussi j'aimerais vous
parler de désert il puisque pour moi les
argiles c'est peut-être un des plus
beaux cadeaux que la nature nous offre
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi donc il
ya trois choses à savoir sur les argiles
la première chose c'est que c'est un
matériau l'utilisation est omniprésente
autour de nous les premières traces de
son utilisation remonte probablement à
la préhistoire
on lui on s'en servait en fait comme
peinture dans les grottes et puis
environ dix mille ans avant jésus-christ
l'invention de la poterie donc la
poterie comme vous savez c'est de la
terre cuite c'est à base d'argile et la
poterie c'était vers un véritablement
une révolution industrielle puisque
toutes les grandes civilisations le
développement de toutes les grandes
civilisations se sont faites avec la
poterie c'est à dire qu'on était capable
de stocker les réserves alimentaires et
les récoltes agricoles et puis tous les
ustensiles à côté par exemple on faisait
la sculpture à base de l'argile les
premières traces d'écriture
on les a retrouvés sur des tablettes
d'argile et puis quelques millénaires
plus tard encore donc aujourd'hui si
vous regardez autour de vous dans vos
maisons
vous verrez qu'il ya énormément d'objets
qui sont faits à base d'argile de terre
cuite alors par exemple la brique le
carrelage
les tuiles la faïence et puis dans vos
dentifrice on en retrouve également dans
les feuilles de papier sur lesquelles
vous écrivez pour la rendre la feuille
plus opaque et plus brillantes et puis
on en retrouve également dans les
plastiques
donc on met des argiles dans les
plastiques pour les rendre par exemple
plus résistants au feu et on s'en sert
également pour stocker les déchets
radioactifs donc si jamais vous avez des
déchets radioactifs à la maison sachez
que vous pouvez utiliser de l'argile
pour les stocker deuxième chose à savoir
sur les argiles et bien c'est c'est un
remède naturel extrêmement polyvalent
naturellement les animaux en fait dans
la nature ils vont servir de l'argile
pour se soigner
donc par exemple s'ils sont blessés ils
vont se rouler dans l'argile pour pour
soigner leurs blessures et aussi ils
vont ils vont aller manger par exemple
ce perroquet en amérique du sud
il mange de l'argile sur une falaise ça
fait partie de son régime alimentaire
il ya une raison un petit peu précises
pour ça c'est qu'à côté il mange des
graines qui ont des molécules toxiques
et le fait de manger de l'argile en
parallèle large il va capter en fait ces
molécules toxiques qui lui permettent de
digérer les graines des humains
également se servent en fait de l'argile
comme thérapie depuis très longtemps
les premières traces de son utilisation
remonte aux anciens égyptiens
donc il avait déjà écrit des manuels de
médecine dans lesquels on retrouve en
fait une utilisation très large de
l'argile et puis ça s'est passé de
génération en génération jusqu'au
naturopathe moderne qui utilise
également l'argile pour se soigner dans
de très nombreux cas alors par exemple
dans pendant la première guerre mondiale
les soldats russes avaient quelques
centaines de grammes d'argile dans leur
trousse de secours et certains régiments
français
il se trouve qu'ils avaient de l'argile
dans leur moutarde et ses régiments là
étaient exempts de dysenterie qui était
une maladie qui attaque et le système
digestif
alors que d'autres régiments en été
ravagée alors ouais l'information qui
m'avait le plus marqué la danse c'était
que les soldats avaient de la moutarde
dans les tranchées
on peut se demander est ce qu'il existe
un lien entre la vie et les argiles
alors il se trouve qu'il ya une théorie
qui dit depuis elle existe depuis les
années 50 un peu près qui dit que
l'origine de la vie sur terre
l'apparition de la vie sur terre est
fortement liée aux argile récemment il
ya une équipe de la nasa
alors la nasa je sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est les gens qui aiment
qu'ils balancent des fusées dans
l'espace sont tout à fait compétent et
sérieux et en fait il ils ont prouvé que
les premières molécules qui était
capable de s'auto répliqué donc c'est
l'ancêtre de l'adn si vous voulez avait
besoin d'un support minérale et il se
trouve que les argiles joue parfaitement
le rôle de ce support minérale alors il
ya une autre équipe qui a un petit peu
écrit cela d'une façon similaire
beaucoup longtemps avant et ils ont
écrit serre dans un livre qu'on appelle
la bible et ils ont dit que ben oui
l'homme est né de la poussière de la
terre
sous-entendu l'argile il ya énormément
de croyance à travers la planète qui
disent finalement la même chose que
l'homme est né de l'argile où il a été
formé dans l'argile alors peut-être que
ça ça s'explique tout simplement par nos
sols quand on regarde le profil d'un
seul vous voyez que ceux en dessous on a
le monde minéral on à la roche est le
seul en fait il vient dégrader la roche
est au dessus on retrouve et bien le
monde vivent donc les plantes elles
prennent leurs racines dans les sols et
on peut se dire que peut-être qu'ils ont
fait lien avec eux duke les plantes sont
à l'origine de la vie sur terre on va
dire que s'il y avait pas de plantes ils
n'auraient nous n'existerions pas non
plus sur cette planète et donc la tétée
qu'ils ont fait le lien avec les sols
tout simplement
après les argiles joue un rôle essentiel
dans les seules ça on l'a appris que
récemment
mais en fait les argiles qui sont en
quelque sorte les résidus ultimes de la
dégradation des roches et bien il
s'associe à la matière organique dans
les seuls pour former ce qu'on appelle
les complexes argileux imite et ses
complexes joue un rôle essentiel dans la
fertilité de nos sols alors que dit la
science moderne sur sur les argiles
qu'est ce qu'on connaît sur les argiles
actuelle
eh bien il a fallu attendre des méthodes
de caractérisation de pointe
si vous voulez la taille des minéraux
argileux
c'est de l'ordre du micromètre un
million de fois plus petit que le maître
donc invisibles à l'oeil nu et donc
c'est comme si vous voulez regarder dans
l'espace dans l'infiniment en loin vous
avez besoin de télescope très très
performant et bien là vous vous regardez
dans l'infiniment petit vous avez besoin
de micro scope également qu'ils sont
très puissants donc là on voit une image
qui est qui fait quelques micromètres de
taille et donc on sait que ces minéraux
sont extrêmement petit et on connaît
maintenant leur structure qui est en
forme de feuillet et ces deux choses
combinés font que l on une surface des
changes qui est réellement important qui
est très grande
si vous amuser donc si on prend un
gramme d'argile en poudre et on s'amuse
à étaler la surface qui est disponible
dans ce g d'argile vous allez couvrir
une surface de 800 m² 800 mètres carrés
c'est l'équivalent de quatre terrains de
tennis dans un gramme d'argile et donc
la surface de ces minéraux et
particulière également puisqu'elle est
capable d'échanger un grand nombre
d'éléments avec le milieu dans lequel
elle se trouve et on sait qu'elle est en
fait en évolution permanente avec le
milieu dans lequel elle se trouve donc
on peut la considérer en quelque sorte
comme un peu comme une matière vivante
alors j'en viens à la construction en
terre donkey quand je disais le large il
joue le rôle de liant dans le matériau
terre c'est ce qui lui donne sa cohésion
c'est grâce à l'argile qu'on peut
construire en terre est tout simplement
l'argile et bien on l'a prélève où la
terre on l'a prélève dans nos sols et
les seuls sont omniprésents sur la
planète partout sur terre on a fait
usage de ce matériau pour construire et
c'est pas du tout anecdotique même
aujourd'hui un tiers de la population
mondiale vit actuellement dans les
constructions en terre l'héritage
architectural qu'on a de la construction
terre et très divers très variés
quelques photos pour illustrer alors on
a ici au maroc
après on a une église en haut à droite
aux états unis on a ces maisons en ronde
en chine et en bas à droite c'est juste
pour montrer que même les animaux ils
construisent en terre donc là c'est une
termites qui construisent ces gratte
ciel
puisque si on compare par rapport à la
taille de la termine c'est véritablement
un gratte-ciel et même en europe et en
france on retrouve beaucoup de
constructions en terre
donc chaque en fait même proche de
l'école ici à moins d'un kilomètre vous
trouvez des constructions en terre ou
bien souvent ça on s'en rend même pas
compte on les voit pas forcément la
terre la difficulté de travail avec la
terre c'est qu'elle est unique
en fait on par exemple on peut pas
écrire des textes normatifs sur la terre
chaque terre est différente
donc chaque région c'est un petit peu
adapté non seulement au savoir-faire qui
existait dans ces régions mais aussi aux
types de terre qu'on retrouvait
finalement dans ces régions par exemple
en france et bien en bretagne vous avez
la bouche c'est un mélange de terre et
de paille dans le sud ouest vous
retrouvez l'adobe cd des briques séchées
et puis dans la région de lyon et du
dauphiné vous avez le pisé qui est tout
simplement de la terre compactée dans un
coffrage et beaucoup de ses maisons sont
plusieurs fois centenaires donc ça
atteste de la durabilité finalement du
matériau et de la qualité du
savoir-faire des artisans donc plus que
le matériau est unique on est dépendant
du savoir faire des artisans
c'est réellement eux qui permettent de
construire avec ce matériau alors quel
est l'avantagé de construire en terre et
bien c'est un matériau local par
excellence puisque dans la plupart des
cas on va chercher soi on peut prélever
le matériau directement sur le site de
construction soit on va le chercher dans
un rayon très faible pour pour
construire et on a besoin de plus de
transformation pour le mettre en oeuvre
ce sont des avantages ont à dire pour un
impact très faible donc en général on
mesure l'impact d'un matériau sur le
film a en fonction de la quantité de co2
qui est émis
et bien la terre et met 100 fois moins
de co2 que le béton si vous voulez si
vous construisez en béton à la place là
où vous pouvez construire en terre c'est
un petit peu comme si vous allez
chercher votre pain en hélicoptère vous
êtes légèrement surdimensionné et
l'autre particularité c'est que ces
réutilisable à l'infini
donc une fois que vous avez
vous avez construit votre maison à la
fin du cycle de vie de la maison soit
vous le réutiliser pas recycler
réutiliser donc ça veut dire qu'on a
exactement les mêmes propriétés qu'au
départ soit vous le remettez à la terre
donc y retourne à la terre et l'autre
chose sur la construction en terre c'est
que de très nombreux témoignages nous
rapporte que eh bien il ya un confort
inégalé dans ces maisons en or cherche
ici à l'école elle cherche un petit peu
a expliqué par des raisons physiques
ce confort on s'est démontrée par
exemple que les argiles qui ont un côté
absorbant un très important et ben reste
active dans les murs et donc les murs en
terre vont naturellement participé à
réguler la qualité de l'air intérieur en
captant par exemple de l'eau de
l'humidité ou des polluants comme le co2
ou même les odeurs qui peut échanger en
fait avec les avec l'air intérieur
après il ya encore beaucoup de choses
qu'on sait pas expliquer et
intuitivement moi je pense que il ya un
lien en fait avec le fait que l'homme a
toujours vécu sur les sols et donc vu
que c'est un matériau kiné qui peut
transformer nous sommes en quelque sorte
en harmonie avec ce matériau à la
différence de tous les matins tous les
autres matériaux qu'on utilise dans la
construction qui sont soient transformés
ou soit extrait de du sol mais de façon
beaucoup plus profonde donc on sait
aujourd'hui construire aux standards
modernes en utilisant la terre donc ça
c'est un projet dans lequel on a
participé c'est dans le quartier de la
confluence à lyon
donc vous pouvez aller visiter est en
quelque sorte il ya un renouveau de la
terre puisque de très nombreux projets
intègrent maintenant de la terre et
aussi des matériaux issus du vivant ce
qu'on appelle les bateaux au bio sourcés
on a il ya une prise de conscience
globale de l'année site nécessité de
réduire l'impact de enfin l'impact de
l'acte de construire sur le changement
climatique et donc je pense qu'il ya un
avenir à jouer avec le matériau terre
sur sur cet impact pour considérablement
réduire notre impact d'actes de
construire
donc si jamais il vous arrive d'être
échoué sur une île déserte où la
prochaine fois que vous serez échoué sur
une île déserte et bien oubliez pas le
matériau argile parce que voyez que vous
pouvez il extrêmement polyvalent vous
pouvez fabriquer votre patrie vous
pouvez vous soigner et vous pouvez même
construire votre maison avec et puis
peut-être quand un jour on retrouvera
des villes entières construites en terre
comme ici au yémen où on a ce qu'on
appelle la manhattan du désert où on a
des gratte-ciel finalement construit en
terre je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]